We've got some breaking news right now.
The Colorado Supreme Court, get this,
has just ruled on a challenge
to Donald Trump's
appearance on the state's 2024 ballot.
I want to go straight to CNN's
Paula Reid Paula.
What does this ruling say?
Well,
if this is a stunning
ruling from the Colorado
Supreme Court saying
that Trump
should not appear on the ballot in 2024.
Now, this is surprising in part
because they are reversing a lower court
that found while Trump
did engage in an insurrection
on January six,
that Section
three of the 14th Amendment
did not apply to presidents,
and therefore
he should not be kept off the ballot.
Now, when we're talking about
this particular section,
this is a civil war
era clause of the Constitution.
And in here
the courts are trying to assess
exactly what that means.
Well, it does specifically mention House
representatives, the Senate,
even electors.
It doesn't say anything about president.
So here
the court was weighing
whether they could
keep former President
Trump off the ballot
because of what happened on January six.
And here,
the Supreme Court,
the highest court
in the state of Colorado,
ruling that he should be disqualified,
he should be kept off the ballot.
But, Wolf,
they're going to stay or pause
this decision
until January 4th
to allow the former president
or anyone else to appeal
to the Supreme Court on this question.
Very significant indeed.
I want to bring in the rest of our team
right now, Ellie Hoenig.
How stunning is this decision?
Well, Wolf, this is a historic decision.
It's a momentous decision
as the Supreme Court itself says.
They are in uncharted territory here.
But it's really important to keep in mind
this is not the last word here.
This is almost certainly
going up to the U.S.
Supreme Court,
which can review the decisions
of a state Supreme court.
In fact, the Colorado Supreme Court
anticipates that possibility.
And for that reason,
they put their own ruling on hold
until January 4th,
anticipating that it will go
up to the Supreme Court.
The practical consequence
as it stands
at this moment,
though, is that Donald Trump
will not be on the Colorado
ballot in the race for president in 2024.
The Supreme Court
almost certainly will take this up.
It's also important
to keep in mind
for the broader context,
there have been dozens
of these challenges
filed across the country, and 18
or so of them have either
failed, been rejected
or been withdrawn by the plaintiffs.
So this is really an outlier.
The Supreme Court
is going to have the final say.
The consequences here are,
of course, enormous normalizing.
Are you surprised by this decision?
Well, Wolf, the
law and really
politics have collided.
And in this instance, law has won.
There is a logic to the decision.
The 14th Amendment provides
is that this direction is
may not hold office.
The lower court
found
that Donald Trump had engaged
in insurrectionist activity
excuse consonant with what
the January six committee found.
And so the only question was legally,
did this apply to a president?
The Supreme Court said it did.
I think because of the earth
shaking nature of the holding,
we thought that
politics might militate against it.
But the courts, as they should
do, have put on blinkers
and applied the Constitution.
Now it'll be up to the Supreme Court
to have the final word.
Yeah, the 14th Amendment to the U.S.
Constitution
says, and I'm quoting now,
No person shall hold any office
who, having previously taken an oath
to support
the Constitution of the United States,
shall have engaged
in insurrection or rebellion
against the same
or given aid
or comfort to the enemies thereof.
Pretty significant.
14th Amendment to the U.S. Constitution.
David, this has never happened before.
Earlier challenges
to get Trump removed
from state ballots for the presidency,
for the presidency have failed.
What does it mean politically for Trump
to be removed
potentially from the Republican
primary ballot in Colorado?
Yeah, Wolf,
I think we're going to go through
a year of this has never happened
before in this presidential election.
So be prepared to keep stating that.
You know, as L.Z.
was noting,
and I do think it is important context
you're bringing up here,
the vast majority of these cases to date
have actually gone the other way.
And I would imagine
that that is not going to be lost
on the Supreme Court
when it looks
at the specifics of this case, but
looks at this issue broadly.
Politically, of course,
Colorado has ten electoral votes.
They were in Joe Biden's column,
not Donald Trump's column back in 2020.
But if you start taking potentially
available electoral votes off the board,
the map to to 70,
even though this was not
part of this 2020
path becomes
more complicated in that way.
We have no indication yet
that the Trump team
was planning to engage
fully in Colorado and
and run a concerted effort
in that state
to play for those electoral votes.
But again, it's the broader concept here
that would be earthshaking
to the election itself.
And as we learned back in 2000,
in Bush v Gore,
you know,
when the Supreme Court gets involved,
looking at a state Supreme Court,
things unexpected
could could potentially happen.
And we'll see
what the Supreme Court does here.
This is always been an issue
that's going to be headed
for the highest court,
because earlier efforts
to get Trump
removed from the state
presidential ballot failed in Minnesota,
in New Hampshire, in Michigan,
and right now in Colorado.
It's going forward to remove him.
Elissa,
how do you expect Trump and his team
to react to this stunning news?
It truly is stunning news,
and I expect this is a five alarm fire
even to the fact of Dave Collins
point that
this doesn't actually
really change the map for Donald Trump.
He's not necessarily
playing for the ten
electoral votes in Colorado,
but it's the precedent it sets.
And it's also
just the mindset
that it signals to voters,
which is for the first time in history,
he is unfit to appear on a ballot
for the presidency.
And of course,
there would be implications
if the Supreme Court upheld this.
I think that you're going
to hear a massive outcry
from him and his team
there needlessly to say, needless
to say, are going to be challenging this.
And I do offer a word of caution
because these
these have obviously appeared
in other states
and mostly been struck down.
There is an argument to be made
for the fact that this should ultimately,
ultimately be left up to the voters.
I've heard this from
quite a few Republicans
who want to see us
move on from Donald Trump,
but they worry about playing
into the hands of him
being able to say the system is rigged.
Now, it's not.
This is the courts working.
They're the way they're supposed to.
But he will quickly frame this
as they're rigging the system
against me in favor of Joe Biden.
Watch for him to say that.
Let's get back to Paula.
So what comes next?
Walk us through the process.
I assume Trump and his lawyers
will start to appeal this, right? Yeah.
Unfortunately for Trump's legal team,
they are likely going to have to work
through the holiday.
Something that they had complained about
are related
to the special counsel investigation
and the filing deadlines there.
And some of the work
that the special counsel they said
was making them do through the holiday.
But here this is going to
this is going to be something
that they're going
to have to pay attention to.
They're literally being given a window
in which to appeal this
to the Supreme Court.
We would fully expect that
they will avail themselves of that.
And then this case,
it is likely that the Supreme Court
would want to take up this question
of exactly
who the 14th Amendment applies to
and if
Trump or any other current
or former president can be removed
from the ballot here.
And while this only applies to Colorado,
this is something that will likely
have reverberations
in other states
that are considering the same issue.
I also want to note that
some people may wonder, well,
if he's not on the ballot,
can people just write him in?
Well, in this opinion,
they specifically say
that the secretary of state
is also barred from counting
any write in votes cast for Trump.
Interesting.
Ellie,
why is the Colorado Supreme Court
right now an outlier here?
Minnesota, as I pointed out,
dismissed a similar lawsuit to this one
back in November.
Well, Wolf, this is
precisely why
we have such dissonance
in the various decisions
that we're getting from different states,
because nobody quite knows
exactly how the 14th Amendment works.
Yes, we have this amendment.
It's very important.
It says that anyone who gave aid
to insurrection, rebellion is ineligible.
But the problem is
neither the Constitution
nor Congress
have given us any further guidance
as to how it works.
And so the theories
that have been advanced by 14th Amendment
proponents have been all over the map.
Literally.
They argued at one point that, well,
it's up to individual
secretaries of state.
They can decide on their own
while every secretary
of state, Democrat and Republican,
to consider that rejected it.
Then they went into
various courts, sometimes
state level, sometimes federal level.
And the failures have across the board
been not so much failures of proving
that Donald Trump was in fact aiding
or engaging in insurrection.
But procedural questions of
how do we make this decision?
Who decides? Is it a judge?
Is it a jury?
What burden of proof?
And the Colorado
Supreme Court satisfies itself
that what was done
here in the trial court, the trial court
judge held a several week
long hearing was enough
and that the law is clear enough
that they made this decision.
But that's going to be the question
for the Supreme Court.
I don't think it will so much be
did Donald Trump engage in insurrection?
I think it will be.
Is there an established procedure
and doesn't violate
Donald Trump's due process rights
to essentially make one up on the fly
and then apply it backwards in time?
Norm,
do you think this ruling
by the Colorado Supreme Court
will ultimately stand?
Well, Wolf,
that'll be up to
the United States
Supreme Court, of course.
But I think that this is one
of the more substantial of the cases.
Ellie is talking about a very deal,
but very
small number
that have been queued up at trial,
gone up on appeal,
been fully briefed
with an evidentiary basis.
And when you just
look at the plain language
of the 14th Amendment,
you put that together with what
the January six committee
found, the testimony
and the evidence
that were taken by the trial court here,
the trial court found with merit
that Donald Trump insurrection
and the government is not going to be so
easily dismissed.
I think the Supreme Court
will wrestle with it.
They'll take it seriously.
And it's very tough
to predict what they'll do.
But it is necessary
as a well-founded legal evidence
for pre-testing.